[Applause]
[Music]
guys its October in fact it's the first
week of October which means we'll be
forgoing the usual format to highlight
some of the new releases launching all
month long and don't worry we'll be
getting to those glorious Italian
nipples soon enough but first let's take
a fantasy journey with Middle Earth
shadow of war the first game took the
world by storm with its orc fighting
action and nemesis system and those have
been cranked up to 11 with the sequel
this time tallien and cala brim borg
can gather followers from other races in
middle-earth and use their own troops to
build strategies against Sauron and his
army and while combat was largely about
gaining powers and hacking your enemies
to bits before the sequel gives you more
options for exploring and fighting your
way shadow war comes to ps4 Xbox one and
PC on Tuesday October 10th but if you
just can't wait that long we've got
plenty of side missions in combat for
you to check out on GameSpot Ubisoft's
first Southpark RPG definitely took some
inspiration from Lord of the Rings but
the fractured but whole is a whole
nother story this time around you'll
choose from 12 superhero classes but
there's not just one hero alliance in
South Park one faction is controlled by
Cartman and his followers while the
other engages in a civil war over
franchise movie rights you can expect
the same level of irreverence humor and
downright ridiculous moments here as the
landmark TV series brings and you can
Don your cape on ps4 Xbox one and PC on
Tuesday October 17th
speaking of Ubisoft games Assassin's
Creed origins is looking to breathe new
life into the series while taking us
back to the days of ancient Egypt it has
the parkour exploration and battles of
the previous games but this time the
combat is much more deliberate with
specific hit boxes on enemies it's a
system you'll definitely have to learn
if you want to survive the game's new
arena battles
we'll see if those features can bring
Assassin's Creed to new heights when
origins comes to ps4 Xbox one and PC on
Friday October 27th and hey it should at
least be better than last year's movie
have you met him in now let's move from
ancient history to alternate history
what if the Nazis had won World War two
and taken over the United States that's
the world BJ blaskowitz faces in
Wolfenstein 2 the new Colossus
fortunately he has a few new tricks up
his sleeve like mixing and matching
weapons when dual wielding and a big ol
hatchet for brutal melee executions the
second American Revolution begins on ps4
Xbox one and PC on Friday the 27th with
a portable nintendo switch version
coming next year
speaking of Nintendo switch it's time
ladies and gentlemen
Mario's next big adventure is super
mario odyssey in fact glistening chests
is just one part of what's shaping up to
be a blockbuster taking its cues from
Super Mario 64 and sunshine Odyssey is
all about open-ended exploration letting
you collect moons coins and all sorts of
special costumes and hats and whatever
order you like
you'll have a bunch of giant kingdoms to
explore when Super Mario Odyssey comes
to Nintendo's switch on Friday the 27th
fingers crossed for a nice waluigi cameo
and those are just a few of the biggest
games we'll be playing all month long
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change I'm looking at you South Park
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with your regular weekly episode of
new releases next Sunday